[موسيقى]
عندما تبدأ في استكشاف الكهوف ، فإنك
تقفز إلى فتحة تحت الأرض ولم
يكن هناك أحد حقًا قبل
أن تكون أول إنسان في هذه
المنطقة وتنظر إلى نافذة زمنية
نتحدث عنها منذ ملايين السنين في الواقع ما
لديك  أمامك مباشرة ،
هذا شعور رائع ،
اسمي ساخن جدًا وأنا مدرب غوص
وأنا أعيش هنا 26 عامًا
في جمهورية الدومينيكان ، تخصصي
هو استكشاف الكهوف عندما بدأت لم
أكن أبحث عن الكهوف  كنت أبحث عن
بعض الأشياء الهندية القديمة في تورينو ووجدت
مداخل كهوف كبيرة وبالطبع كمدرب غوص
أنت مهتم بما
يحدث هنا وهذا عندما بدأت
بالفعل في استكشاف كهوفي الأولى كنت
رائدًا في استكشاف الكهوف
في جمهورية الدومينيكان  لديها الآن
أكثر من 140 كهفًا ما زلنا
نستكشفها وهنا في بايا هنا لدينا
حديقة وطنية ضخمة وجميلة في هذه
الحديقة الوطنية تشبه الجبن السويسري
ولديها عدد كبير من الكهوف تحت الماء
عندما أفعل هذا اليوم  بالطبع أنت
تبحث كمستكشف كهوف
بطريقة مختلفة تمامًا ، فربما تجد
ممرًا مختلفًا أو ربما يمكنك
توصيل مجموعة كاملة من الكهوف التي
تبحث دائمًا عن فتحات صغيرة
للعثور على أشياء جديدة تغوص في المحيط المفتوح
عندما  لديك مشكلة صغيرة ،
فأنت في طريقك للخروج من الماء وهي
الصعود إلى كهف ، ولديك بيئة علوية
لا يمكنك الصعود إليها
[موسيقى]
عندما أذهب إلى المحيط ، يكون لديك ضوضاء في
كل مكان يمكنك الاستماع إلى محركات القارب
التي يمكنك  استمع إلى ضوضاء
تحت الماء عندما تذهب إلى كهف
لن تستمع إلى أي شيء فقط
لفقاعاتك وهذا بالنسبة لي أحد
أروع الأشياء على وجه الأرض لا يوجد ضوضاء
على الإطلاق غوص الكهوف هو شغفي وما
زلت بعد 20 عامًا أحب ذلك.
أحب تعليم الناس القيام
بالغوص في الكهوف بطريقة آمنة ، أبلغ من العمر 59 عامًا ، لذا أحتاج إلى
شخص ورائي للقيام بنفس الأشياء
عندما أتقدم في السن ، من الجيد بالنسبة
لي أن أرى الشباب الذين هم في
هذا لطيف  شيء لطيف لطيف لاستكشاف الكهف
أنا سعيد جدًا  ما زالوا يسألون
الرجل العجوز كيف يفعل بعض الأشياء
[موسيقى]